let's say that Y is equal to 7/2 the x
squared minus X power what is the
derivative of Y derivative of Y with
respect to X and like always pause this
video and see if you can figure it out
well based on how it this has been
color-coded ahead of time you might
immediately recognize that this is a
composite function or it could be viewed
as a composite function if you had a V
of X which if you had a function V of X
which is equal to 7 to the X power and
you had another function U of X U of X
which is equal to x squared minus X then
what we have right over here y Y is
equal to 7 to something so it's equal to
V of and it's not just V of X it's V of
U of X instead of an X here you have the
whole function U of X x squared minus X
so it's V of U of X and the chain rule
tells us that the derivative of Y with
respect to X and you'll see different
notations here sometimes you'll see it
written as the derivative of V with
respect to u so V prime of U of x times
the derivative of U with respect to X so
that's one way you could do it or you
could say that this is equal to this is
equal to the derivative the derivative
of V with respect to X derivative or
sorry derivative of V with respect to u
DV d u times the derivative of U with
respect to X derivative of U with
respect to X and so either way we can
apply that right over here so what's the
derivative of V with respect to u what
is V prime of U of X well we know we
know let me actually write it right over
here if V of X is equal to 7 to the X
power V prime of X would be equal to and
we prove this in other videos where we
take x derivatives Exponential's of
bases other than e this is going to be
the
log of 7 times 7 to the X power so if we
are taking v prime of U of X then notice
instead of an X everywhere we're going
to have a U of X everywhere so this
right over here this is going to be
natural log of 7 times 7 to the instead
of saying 7 to the X power remember
we're taking V prime of U of X so it's
going to be 7 to the x squared minus x
power x squared x squared minus X power
and then we want to multiply that times
the derivative of U with respect to X so
u prime of X well that's going to be 2x
to the 1st which is just 2x minus 1 so
we're going to multiply this times 2x 2x
minus 1 so there you have it that is the
derivative of Y with respect X you could
we could try to simplify this or I guess
reexpress it in different ways
but the main thing to realize is look
we're just going to take the derivative
of the 7 to the this to the U of X power
with respect to U of X so we treat the U
of X the way that we would have treated
an X right over here so it's going to be
natural log of 7 times 7 to the U of X
power we take that and multiply that
times u prime of X and once again this
is just an application of the chain rule